Who am I to be doing this enterprise
with you why am i doing it what's what's
what's my goal well I'm the founder of
the Berkman Center for Internet and
Society at Harvard soon to be the
Berkman climb Center but that's another
story the Berkman Center goes back to
basic vision of cyberspace as tripartite
in its power structure three huge forces
the force of states of nations the whole
idea of traditional law as we've
understood it the force of corporate
power market extraordinarily powerful
economics and the force of University of
what you might think of as ethics of
truth of the idea that well the Socratic
idea that if we combine our diversity if
we join it and learn from each other all
we have to teach each other then we have
a force and you can see that it's been a
force down through the ages but here in
its way suddenly at the advent of the
internet the idea that suddenly we are
universal in our connection in a way
we've never been before we find
ourselves in a new environment hostile
in many respects into
testing intriguing but altogether a
shift from an orientation that allows us
to be individual to one in which we live
in a connected space I'm a professor of
law law in the sense of process law in
the sense of Socrates law in the sense
of modes of behavior that allow us to
get along and I believe that the number
one question posed by internet is one of
governance not the question how do we
govern the internet that question if you
understand its dimensions doesn't have
an answer but the question rather is how
do we recognize that we as individuals
and as institutions as universities as
states as corporations recognize that we
are in a new environment and in a new
environment are challenged to learn how
to live and thrive in it in that
environment the question that we face is
how do we govern ourselves and the
approach that I would like to follow
with you draws its inspiration from the
American jury and from poker two of my
favorite subjects but both with the
element in common that people sit around
the table and they play as equal players
in the rhetorical game that goes back
and forth to come to a decision so I
invite you to come play retort
poker with me learn about the original
conception of the American jury not
necessarily where it's come I'm not
teaching you a technical law class but
the idea of discourse the idea of
listening as a means of persuading these
are the skills that I would like to see
us practice and share